more confusion over masked mandates
republican governors say they were
caught off guard by the cdc's a sudden
change to the rules last week
big businesses are now split on what to
do about people
covering their faces former surgeon
general jerome adams says biden
really screwed things up the cdc made
the right play call
but they fumbled the ball at the one
yard line the communication was just
quite frankly abysmal on this we were
completely blindsided by this there was
no nuance
and again you've got whiplash from last
week to this week so
i think there needs to be some
improvement in communication but the
science is sound
and president biden not helping to clear
up the confusion
ultimately those who are not vaccinated
will end up paying the price the
vaccinator will continue to be protected
against severe illnesses
but others may not be if you're not
vaccinated some people may want to
continue
to wear a mask even if they are fully
vaccinated
that's a decision they can make some
businesses may want to continue
to require wearing masks let's all be
kind and respectful to one another
as we come out of this pandemic so juan
i was listening to that it's the first
time i heard that turn off your phone
degan
um
[Laughter]
all right um in this case like when you
listen to biden there's
there's like hey do it if you want do it
if you don't want it seems to me we've
said this before that it's actually
going to be up to americans to lead
because we cannot be sued we cannot be
canceled
is it time juan to start burning our
masks like they burned bras
in the 1960s
i'm trying to make wait we can't be sued
so why should we
i got confused why why did you say that
greg because
corporations and politicians are worried
more about covering
their butts than uncovering faces score
okay okay got it now uh so i think that
a lot of people from what i saw
is that a lot of people still are
concerned even though the cdc guidance
came out people
do have concerns about protecting
themselves and their families i i can
understand it
i thought it was really good news today
that in that little bit that we just
heard from biden
he said that for the first time now you
know the cases
infection rates are down in all 50
states deaths are down in all 50 states
and vaccinations he said we're now at 60
percent
uh of the american people at least one
shot i think that's
fantastic i think that's evidence that
we're making progress so
i mean you know i heard i hear the
critics say hey we
why isn't biden telling people they can
do without the mask if they're
vaccinated he's been slow to tell us to
take off the mess then now i'm hearing
people say
hey i think he was too fast to tell us
to take off the mess so
at some point i think hey maybe this is
just politics because i'm getting dizzy
trying to make sense of what the critics
are saying i don't know tegan i haven't
heard a single
person say he's been too fast with
anything
but uh we predicted this before keystone
pipeline oh the keystone but
absolutely right yeah that's a good
point uh
the spokesperson for pepperidge farm
goldfish is right on that one
we predicted that like any time there is
going to be a surge or a surprise case
the media is going to kick into their
fear-mongering
prophet models like you know bill maher
has been diagnosed with uh
with covid after he was you know got
this test
and that's like gotta scare everybody
who already got the vaccine
that we're always gonna go through this
right i ignore any story about bill
maher
i ignore it like i ignore his show so
i hope he's okay sure he is because he's
vaccinated correct
uh in terms of the democrats said
governors
and loyal lightfoot was clearly not
happy with this mass guidance out of the
white house
because again maybe they weren't
consulted and they're starting to lose
that kind of control and power that
they've at least some of it they've
accumulated
in the last year but some of these
republican governors
who are complaining about the
announcement out like oh it's too fast
stop whining you shut down an economy
estate
overnight this is simple a simple
recommendation it's mask was on now it's
masked off
be nimble when the outcome is in your
favor
stop complaining about it know when to
shut up
and by the way california is taking a
month
to implement this uh mass guidance these
cdc guidelines so i'm
guess that's based on how long people
still wore those i'm with her
t-shirts yes yes i still have mine
remember i got one and i got one in ohio
it was beautiful dana is you know
isn't the aren't people hiding behind
this abundance of caution
when it's an abundance of fear of
litigation
sure that's all good yeah we're talking
about we've been taught liability um
protection for a long time because
basically all of these companies if you
like well in a way if they were waiting
for the cdc
to say that if you're vaccinated you
don't have to wear masks anymore and so
that actually i do think gives
some companies like the ones that we put
up on the board target making the
decision today
to say okay well the cdc said this the
criticism about the cdc
and the moving too fast was really
coming from the left
from the scientists i mean it wasn't as
much even though i know dagon you're
right that some of the governors were
complaining about that
and it does seem like all of a sudden
the government is saying okay actually
business you land this plane you figure
it out for us but that might be okay
i think the one thing that i really
really like to get some answers on is
just two weeks ago or last week excuse
me last week rachelle belinsky she's the
head of the cdc she testifies in front
of congress
and they're grilling her about the mask
mandates and she's
just stalwart absolutely not we need to
wear a mask we need to wear a mess
then all of a sudden on wednesday night
that tell the white house
that it's okay now and then they tell
they wait till thursday morning to tell
the president that he rolls this out at
one o'clock on thursday
to me the scientist the science didn't
change
in the last four days what changed was
the political winds
and i would imagine that they i'm not
against the decision that they made or
the announcement that they made but i
think we should all just be honest about
what really changed here to me was the
politics
jesse don't you find it strange that it
you never can really predict
a political issue that becomes kind of
like a phenomenon
and the fact that the mask is now a kind
of a focal point
that creates so many different kind well
actually two factions
with some other ones in between but it
is kind of interesting that it's it
becomes more of a symbol
it's not a political symbol it's a it's
a it's individual freedoms
you're right the country's either scared
or confused
and here's why i went to a wedding in
nashville this weekend you get on the
plane
the cockpit tells you you got to keep
your mask on the whole flight and the
stewardesses just keep
feeding food and beverages so half the
people on the plane
have their masks off and then you can't
go to school
and then you gotta go to go to the
bathroom and you're basically grinding
on someone to get out into the aisle
seat
but politicians say you can't dance yes
right
and then i get down there and vanderbilt
is having
college graduation and they know the
transmission's nothing outside
and the college prez is vaccinated and
he won't go up on stage
and hand out diplomas he's too scared he
sits down
the students 22 year olds double mask
broad daylight
get up there wave and then they mail
them their diplomas in the mail
and then on the way home i go through
security i still have to take my shoes
off
yes because of the shoe bomber years ago
really
yeah and then they pulled me aside for
additional screening
and they wiped me down to see if i have
explosive residue on my hands like
i'm jida jesse or something meanwhile
you can cross the southern border
and they will buy you a bus ticket to
new york so i get to new york i turn on
the news
and there's like a slashing spree on the
subway blood everywhere
cuomo comes out and says hey don't
forget to wear a mask on the subway
meanwhile like he's jailing people for
not social distancing
and touching literally every girl he
sees and then his partner in crime
bill de blasio he's bribing people to
get
vacs with fast food meanwhile obesity is
like the number one component
to get the coronavirus in the first
place so you have
people either confused or scared and
politicians just
pit you against each other to win
elections greg
in the tsa's defense jesse was looking
really rough
on sunday morning at the airport
slightly suspicious with the glasses and
everything
guilty i i think i think g hat jesse
jihad jesse is going to
get a repeat on this show yeah hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it
anywhere else